I want to talk about when they see us
this is it's really a harrowing story
it's heartbreaking this story 1989
everyone knows the story of the Central
Park five wrongfully charged and
convicted committing this terrible crime
took the park and this has got to a bed
first of all how did you come to play
this role that you play your play a
mother who's in this situation that was
a nightmare for any mom to be in your
son's been wrongfully convicted
anyone in this project because I was so
passionate about it I am such a fan of
justice and this was an injustice so I
had to reach you know Ava I reached out
to her but she doesn't have a voicemail
so I sent the text I sent to DM you know
I did everything I could to reach this
woman to say hey girl hey I'll be anyone
in this series and I ended up playing uh
Dolores wise the mother of one of the
boys yeah this is I mean it's
beautifully done it's a story that is
it's as relevant today as it would have
been in 1989 in some ways may be more
relevant about as we're trying to sort
out it's an ongoing thing in our country
and it will be for a long time you know
sort out our past sort out these in
justices but this story is just so tough
to watch also anyone who's a parent and
see what these kids it was hard to do
this was the only series I've ever been
on where we were provided crisis
counseling after working you know what
I'm saying and I you know and I it was
either gonna be that or tequila so I was
like let me let me call the number yeah
tequila's pretty good yeah why not both
yeah exactly
well we have a clip here
can you set this up for us for when they
see us yes my son has been taken to
prison for something he did not knew do
he's only 16 but he went straight to
Rikers yeah and it was very difficult
for the mother to get to see him all the
time and this is one of their one of
their visits
this look at this clip from when they
see us keep it aside from my commissary
go tell mom not not much ain't no Blair
House 1020 just just add to my book give
you ain't got it little
[Music]
you know I don't know what it takes to
do that I don't know what it takes to do
a scene like that it's hard I mean when
I have a son so looking into the face of
jor-el jor-el was like looking at my own
baby so yeah yeah that gets you there
yes yeah